what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Andor episode 8 today John how's it
going I'm excited for Rebellion how are
you sir I'm doing great ladies and
gentlemen I have watched all the tales
of the Jedi with YouTuber Omni media and
let me tell you that's the progressively
just gets more awesome so keep a look
out for those reactions as as well as
it's such a all-nighter of editing
tonight and it's well worth it it's
worth it to get it up
um anyway uh guys leave a like use the
force leave that like and also subscribe
click the notification Bell get notified
for all the Star Wars stuff coming even
though we're only allowed through
notification Bells a day full length
Reaction watch along as we sync up with
your own copy for and or whatever else
available for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page thank you for all the
support to everyone who has joined it
really is a major contribution to the
channel thank you guys and uh let's get
to it we just gotta do this
foreign
safety
to put those on roller coasters I was
planning on calling you in to fill some
gaps in the report we were scheduling
that but now we've both had our mornings
interrupted because you keep submitting
requests to the Bureau of Standards data
center looking for Cassian Andor doesn't
quit you've been at the Bureau of
standards for less than a month and
you've filed five false inquiries six
actually
Cassian and where is a murderer and a
threat to the Empire I had been trying
with the limited tools available to find
him so this is about Public Safety no no
no no much more than that
she's your Lutheran I'm just trying to
clear my name one would think you'd want
to leave ferricks as far behind as
possible one would be wrong
team up tell me what's not in Lieutenant
Blevins report that I need to know I
have no idea I wasn't allowed to see the
report
you signed it I was given no choice
yeah team up come on tell her that you
think he's involved with the Rebellion
you should be upstairs by now give him
Blevins report let him read it to keep
him in there of all days we have time
and play Metallica at the top volume
starting to feel like Westworld oh good
call yeah
again the the way this show is shot
should not be overlooked
Michelle look how gorgeous this is guys
yeah the thief was a local named Cassian
Andor he was wanted for the murder of
two corporate security officers
all ready to go sir if someone there is
talking we need to be listening it's a
large investment come on she's been
right so much of the time
help her out yes help out the empire
Barracks was a mistake
it's the first one he's made
drill down is exactly what I want to do
sir drill down find Andor and get a hunt
started man and or was so integral to
the hunt for the rebellion and now he's
in the system
the Endor story is important
thank you
foreign
if not all of you are wondering how we
risk standing before you with our
weapons
potent question
it's them shoes on you won't need to
have answered very often but laws
electricity
Ah that's what the shoes do
yikes that looks painful
rubber soles
our flaws are tongues to its deal
do your time productively keep to your
line and this needed me more than a
memory
good luck dear
this is almost like Face-Off I sold a
double murder and found the killer in
two days I was overly ambitious yes but
time was slipping away in the
opportunity was real
it was good you just said it
can one ever be too aggressive in
preserving order
my man
foreign
I love this
actual order you know one can aspire to
form such an organization
this was unit 5 2D Andy Circus
no way
it's about time seven men each table
my name is Kino Loy I'm the 5-2d unit
manager snoke's Origins they only come
to pick up the dead and bring their
replacements
you're mine now
off program
back to work
listen up this is cool
I have 249 days left of my sentence I
have a free hand in how I run this room
I'm used to seeing my room in the top
three on the level you will want to keep
that happening I'm sensing you
understand he understands you problems
with another inmate I will know before
you do
losing hope your mind
look at yourself
don't ever slow up my lines
table five
I would never mess with this guy Stakes
established
what would I do exactly hear me where I
am this time tomorrow with seven men
nine to swing I'll be feeding the table
so it might be a little different on the
box they're calling him
oh
don't what the hell is going on
[Music]
come on boys
let's go let's go someone has to really
clear up what what it is they're doing
foreign
visual learner and or
are they building weapons for the Empire
it's either that or like pieces of
Transit units or something yeah the new
legislation is definitely having an
effect the rebels might have thought
that over before blowing up aldani
well good luck feeding the Galaxy I'm
off to feed myself charity begins at
home
[Laughter]
Great Exchange
already
looked away we'll find a way to explain
it
so we've given up on hiding it how much
are we worrying about
four hundred thousand whoo
what is that in US dollar one million
billion dollars
a subtlety my guy
got you
it's like the line at Costco
are they planning a breakout
looks like it dangerous time oh they
know do you feel under threat personally
here yes
I'm at Great risk of ingesting too much
of this nourishing Chamberlain
Hospitality chorus on pricks
you see the White Lies that's the floor
well it's cold really hot the white
lights start flashing you've got seven
seconds to get to yourself
sensors of the floor two men in one cell
it's an instant fry where were you back
when they were building stuff this place
sucks water night light toilet flips
down you've got a plate spoon and shaver
the tube
you can get as much as you want
to like us healthy and fueled oh my God
this place is awesome but perhaps in a
few shifts
we can pull the winner
gets taste with their food
top table with flavor last place gets
fried
wow this is so awful so what did you do
nothing
I know that lately
they doubled everyone's number last
month
p-o-r-d
what people must be talking about it
about what the legislation I don't know
anything about it don't ever look at the
number double triple it doesn't matter
hey you're into they don't want you
anymore you're not get straight with
that
live streaming
those days are over
here
what
you'll find out
hot floor
at least he's looking out for them it's
like a Stern uncle
tighten up
diabolical design for this place
[Music]
foreign
way to clean yourself
ah Disney you cowards show some butts
like
brings off two there are 18. the four is
struggling
right hands away yeah
let's go five
you're getting fast and or you okay
hidden Jam it's all help yeah come on
man
uh oh
I'm afraid for this old guy I'm afraid
for Olaf
you just taking a breather come on guys
you got a chance of winning the shift
today
what have you done now
apparently I'm throwing a party I hope
the boys had to carry you back here no
it travels fast she fell
that's the Troopers
she fell trying to pry open the old
Woods flood King
she wanted to see if the tunnel under
the hotel was still open
that's a good idea where did you go
is the big one reunited I have no idea
why were you I was about to come and
look in oh they're hunting him that's
right
this is a fight to the death fell
yeah stop putting your relationship
first vowel
I told you up front
struggle will always come first we take
what's left
struggle is real this is the first
episode we're cutting around there's so
many different characters
from all the episodes
and true Ensemble I need to look for
something in the back
it's been awful
for a while
I feel like this is going to cause some
problems I don't trust that guy at the
back
yeah literally catching it with everyone
we can't she could point us in the right
direction she's asking us she knows more
than we do so much more she might have a
league more likely it's the ISB work in
her radio you're guessing and you're
slipping
this is why you need each other I'm
thinking clearly and you're not
tell me to shut it down
you're thinking emotionally
I've just been hiding for
you it's all different now
we're going loud vulnerability is
inevitable
[Music]
people will suffer foreign
took out her lip piercing
to say she's a mirror and then they
transitioned through looking through
Windows some [ __ ] symbolism
you're more obvious coordinate
alternatives for Sega Milo we
AK
romailo
don't do it mate I say go for it
oh
come on why won't you tell me where are
they taking my father tell me where is
he where is my father oh [ __ ] I hope you
don't snitch
let's go let's go
move it
that's the guy demanded a position
fix clean
office run
get her
oh dude
wow
cool transition
that dude looks so familiar Garrison at
old Donny someone comment is that you oh
my God
tell me what you've got well how about a
full set of Imperial Drive adapters I
also got three sealed steer guard
targeting deflectors
at what cost
enter Krieger
I'm the one who says we'll die with
nothing
if we don't put aside our petty
differences pity
I am the only one
with Clarity of purpose oh careful
a bit of a luxury I'd argue to a man
who's hiding in cold caves
and begging for spare parts
no sale today lucid good luck with
antokriga ugh
Enemy of My Enemy dude
that'll actually help
wanted to see him
quickly well play jeez
on a dime
hello Bix
[Music]
torture chair
foreign
damn
fascinating way to end all right kick it
off John I love this episode I thought
this was great I uh
you know the
introduction to the prison Colony alone
or this prison compound really and just
the ruthless efficiency and the way in
which it is so clean and sterile and
organized and yet so cold and Sinister
and just the amount of like that one
shot when he looks down and sees all the
different walkways with all the
different people you know you really get
a sense for the vastness which I think
this show is really good at and I really
appreciate that after that all you know
thing in sort of the
I don't know if you call it the first I
guess it's like the first couple acts of
the show you know for him to land out
here and for him to yeah not flash back
to a point in the past where he was
vacationing but to flash you know not
flash but you know time Jump a little
bit too here he is on vacation doing not
much and yet still the repercussions of
the Rebellion have come for him uh that
one guy says like there's been a lot of
that lately just like people doing not
much and then getting thrown into places
like this you know and it's got to do
with uh you know the hit on aldani and
all that stuff and yeah checking in with
everybody it's funny you know this is
episode eight so we're technically past
the halfway point in the series but this
almost felt like turning the record over
and starting side B because yeah you are
doing a big check-in with everybody
you're seeing what the board looks like
now and you're also getting this pretty
harsh uh you know
is consequence for Cassian so I thought
this was a really interesting
episode overall and a really nice again
sort of place Setter for what's to come
in these last two acts of the Season you
know
what did you think sir it was it was
really good it was great it was in just
like every episode it's been it's been
consistently really good
I can't complain I I think it they I
like the the irony and all the
juxtaposition of what this prison lays
forward this false sense of we're not
like every other prison look at us we
take care of our prisoners you have food
water cleanliness uh we we look after
you but that's also about like setting
this sort of competition and there's a
there's a there's a underlying Insidious
ruthlessness that just sort of
percolates throughout the entire system
and there's a lot of
situations and people like Andy circus's
character whoever he is is sort of a
they talk about mirroring in this
episode and it's sort of a mirroring of
who and or could possibly become if he
stuck around here long enough he could
morph into this individual and I loved
how there was such an intensity there in
such a such an oppression there and
watching this felt like just so like
pure sci-fi I said at one point this
kind of this episode kind of reminds me
of Westworld and there is such a
Westworld like quality to it the the
more progress like well you can kind of
go down a path of all right well
obviously it's not going to stay here
you know he's going to get out in some
way and I liked how because the show is
called Andor and there's all these
different characters you're cutting
around everyone here and it's all
centering around and or like this
everyone's mentioning him at least
except for Monmouth but everyone else is
mentioning him at least once and that's
the kind of the funny part with what
they're doing when mon mothma because
while she's working on getting this
money to help fun
um you know funnel money around he'll
find the rebellion and stuff
she's the one they ought to look out for
and everyone's so focused on Andor and
like the Empire's hunting and or Cyril's
after Andor
um you know Val and
the same time yep are after and or like
everyone's looking for Andor
but no one's got their eye on my mothma
except for maybe her husband you know
and I I love I love that because it is
her working in the shadows like like a
lot of these people but she's working in
the shadows and she's she can actually
actually have probably the most
instrumental part so it was fun hop into
everyone who's all like and or Android
gotta find and Order and yet no you
don't really have to worry about Andrew
like he's he's not really he's not
really the threat he's locked up and uh
he's keeping his mouth shut you know so
I I think the exploring the prism system
and the impression and with the show
that's already dealt you know with the
political aspects of like police
brutality and then going in here with
dealing with the incarceration system I
think it's a fascinating commentary to
throw into all of this and yeah I loved
it because they they try to show you the
sense of camaraderie but really it's
it's not about that it in some ways they
do condition you to be someone who could
potentially be a servant for the Empire
after after all said and done oh yeah I
think that's brilliant the breadth of
the apparatus of the Empire I think it's
I think it's brilliant and yeah a lot of
it's just like check up and catch up on
with other characters where you are
probably just gonna get more plot Point
advancements characters like Bix who
it seems like she's sort of torn between
she joined the rebellion and she seems
like she's in the rebellion in some way
should have got like a toe dipped in
there you know and and uh it's probably
gonna be propelled like you're watching
stories where it's like I don't know
what's going to happen to the people on
pharynx is and we're gonna try to return
there but then like everyone he's loved
and cared about is dead is that going to
be the final component piece to him
going I need to join the Rebellion you
know like what is that final thrust I
just remember there's a line in Rogue
one when they are breaking out of the
prison with Donnie Yen
um chirit and all them when he is like
this isn't my first time or something
like that so I wonder if this is
is it Easter egg it's this time he's
referring to this time it could be he's
not going to be around for six years
there's not going to be a six year no
there was actually a really definitive
time Jump in here it's the first time
they've really defined a time Jump with
the 30 days where you watch how he's
slowly withering uh uh and like there's
so many story lines that are happening
here Cyril is a very compelling
character as well
you kind of root for all these there's
some of these bad people you kind of
root for like even
um uh oh my God so many names but to
keep up with so many Star Wars names in
the last 24 hours
yes Deidra there's times with her room I
find myself rooting for her even though
I yeah but then when they do flip it
what was neat about this episode is when
they do have the guy from the hotel is
locked up in the hotel and then she has
Bix about to sit in the chair the
torture interrogation chair it's the
first time
at least in my personal viewing
experience where you do see oh yeah she
is a villain she is an antagonist to
this and as much as they flush her
character out where she seems like the
the woman in the workspace is trying to
prove herself to all these men and
they're not giving her a fair Shake even
when she's in the room trying to tell
them here's what I'm trying to do and
the guy's not really listening and it
needs that guy to step in and be like no
you just wish to listen to her like oh
yeah now I listen to her because he said
so you know I I I think I find myself
like rooted for her in the workspace and
then now that she's actually in the
field and getting [ __ ] done I'm going oh
wait never mind you're bad I forgot
about that actually yeah yeah absolutely
I get so caught up in the immediacy of
what you're experiencing and I think
that's what they do such a good job at
doing is getting you to experience what
these characters are experiencing even
with a character like Cyril who are like
nah man you were wronged I want you back
in the field you're doing everything
right team up
yeah but once he's out there I'm like ah
crap no it's Cyril no you're gonna bad
you're ruining everything for everyone
Sarah so it's it's I like the I like the
tug and pull it does with the audience
because it gets you to understand
everyone everyone's so human
and even with
um Mommy and or uh how she Marva how
you know the last time we left off with
her it seemed like all right she's gonna
be a badass setting up for the rebellion
and while she's trying to do it she's
you know she's much older and
you can see that she's not as strong and
the thing that's kind of keeping her
alive is and keeping her going is just
that feeling of Hope when still it feels
hopeless you know just holding on to the
feeling that the rebels are going to
show up and plow through here but they
haven't yet and uh I I think what they
that's what they do such a good job at
um illustrating is the the harsh pull
the harshness of everything of of the
yearning of Hope and and praying for
things to happen that just won't because
the show's so deliberate it takes his
time and lets you uh simmer and all the
ominous qualities it has so yeah I
thought it was a fascinating episode saw
Guerrera herrera's here that's right
yeah it was it commands the screen for
that whole five minutes like we're
watching him is such a is such a unique
pleasure because I remember the first
time we saw him on screen in that role
as some people were like man he's really
non all over the scenery and he does but
it's so engrossing to watch his little
ticks and mannerisms and he does come
with this sort of other world league
almost crazed quality and I loved his
little architect style speech like I'm
not going to work with these people
they're separatists and these people are
you know a whole bunch of other ists
that I'm not gonna name off in tandem
properly but like seeing I love the
nuances they cast on both the new the
the Empire and the Rebellion because
especially in the Rebellion I think this
episode did two things really nicely and
in a really sophisticated fashion and
the first of which
is they you know it's easy to think of
the Rebellion especially in context of
Star Wars and think like okay you can
think back to the original movies and
you think back to those coordinated
strikes and the x-wings and ah you know
like there's there's an uplift and
there's a you know uh something that
makes you want to whoop your fist and
it's it's fun and here they really zero
in on the idea that that the Rebellion
while a hopeful thing and a and a net
positive arguably for you know Liberty
and equity in the galaxy is also a
really harsh sacrifice that is going to
Scar and maim a lot of people who have
good intent and you know you're gonna
basically in pursuing this action you
are going to cause a lot of innocent
folks who aren't really in the fight
Pain and grief and suffering and I think
that is something to be reminded of
because yeah there's no pleasantry of
that variety and War and then with the
sawgrera scene you also get the sense
like okay there are Pockets there are
all these different figures who are all
kind of commonly United in that they are
against what the Empire is doing and yet
they are completely splintered and
fractured and even though you have that
appeal of you know I am trying to put
all these things aside and realize that
the only way we're gonna make any sort
of difference is if we make a
coordinated effort and yet you can also
see how the ideology is so important
because it's like what are you going to
replace the Empire with and so even
though you're sitting there going oh man
put come on dude like we can't afford to
zero in on these squabbles but I I think
that that that line that word they hang
up on Petty uh is an interesting one
because yeah to uh Lutheran it is petty
and to uh saw it's kind of everything
it's the ideology it's it's you know
what will we put in place after this and
I don't want to work with any number of
people who don't you know share my
vision of what that Equity looks like
and that's just another facet of how
difficult any Rebellion you know
Revolution situation must be I would
imagine and yeah I really like that they
choose to do that to show just how harsh
and difficult it is from The Hope side
and then also just how sort of
I don't know you know like with Nazis
back in the day there's always that
thing of like I was just following
orders you know I was just you know this
is what I grew up in and this is you
know it was my job I was doing what I
thought I was supposed to do and there's
a lot of that within the Empire
obviously as well and so yeah it's like
it's it's weird to slip and watch the
overlapping Venn diagrams as characters
yeah get rub up against uh
just crappy paradigms within the social
etiquette and hierarchy that really
would be Universal if they could just
see past a few aspects of the ideology
and so it's interesting to have moments
where you root for characters like Mira
or Cyril because in ways you know that
there are you know human qualities and
and things that probably aren't that
different and to me one of the scariest
things about life and one of the most
fascinating things is conviction because
you know two people can see the same
thing entirely differently and have
little to no hope of harmonizing those
viewpoints and I think this show does a
really wonderful job illustrating that
and I think this is an episode that
exemplifies that uh verily
so to speak yeah couldn't agree more all
right guys got to get to some editing
but um what did you guys think about
this episode leave your thoughts down
below uh go ahead and uh subscribe and
click that bells or any other points you
want to make
nah I'm good there's no other characters
I mean Andy Circus was fun to see in
human just regular circus form not as a
snoke or anything like that
as Kino was a good time yeah
it's true did talk about it already
right didn't we
yep okay then now we're good all right
okay we're good right now alrighty guys
thank you so much for being here and uh
we'll see you all soon
[Music]